[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'abord toute l'équipe et moi même avons
une pensée en cette période de crise
sanitaire pour toutes celles et tous
ceux qui nous regardent aujourd'hui est
le plus de notre équipe c'est une de
l'empathie aussi de l'énergie parce que
moi je suis nouvelle en politique et
donc c'est quelque chose de différent
pour moi et c'est ce qui fait le plus de
notre équipe
[Applaudissements]
le point fort de notre programme qui
nous différencie des deux autres listes
de la ville c'est ce que nous avons
appelé l'assemblée vie sinoise notre
ville va être amené à prendre des
décisions très importantes pour son
avenir et nous pensons qu'il est
important de composer une assemblée vie
chinoise qui rassemble non seulement des
conseils de quartier mais aussi des
habitants des associations des
commerçants pour prendre les décisions
stratégiques qui vont impacter la ville
sur les décennies à venir
[Applaudissements]
après cette crise
on sent bien que il faut inventer le
monde d'après le monde d'après est
toujours lié à des choix politiques des
choix politiques qui se reflète par des
choix budgétaires et la première
décision sera sur les affectations
budgétaires notamment une étude de du
budget défini pour le centre communal
d'action sociale le ccas
car la crise nous a montré que après cet
élan de solidarité que nous avons vécu
des personnes de la ville sont quand
même en en situation de difficulté nous
devons les accompagner
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]